well i'll tell you who is benefiting the
most
for one it's these woke absurd
politicians who
give us mindless platitudes and
ridiculous statements of no more police
that'll solve the problem
rashid's life i agree let's get rid of
all the police right now how about we do
this
i think your idea was better give notice
let's have every cop in the country say
all right in 30 days we won't be working
you know why
they're giving a heads up to the
criminals as well as the regular
citizens they may as well announce the
purge is going to be a real thing
because all the criminals are going to
be like
30 days it's on baby but i'll tell you
who else is making money
these activists who claim to fight for
this stuff they're cashing out
i think a lot of people have seen this
story already this black lives matter
leader
apparently bought a a massive mansion
and a bunch of other moderately priced
and and well actually they're
fairly expensive homes so this bm this
black lives matter lady i guess she has
what like three homes that are like 400
to 500k
yeah and then one that's 1.4 million
yeah that's really good for a marxist
multiple properties kind of like you
know kind of like socialist bernie
sanders he's got what three homes
good for him i'm glad they've been able
to successfully capitalize on socialism
so we have this story from the post
millennial black lives matter
i guess activist says story about
co-founders oh
black lives matter says this yeah story
about co-founders new multi-million
dollar home
are fueled by white supremacy i feel so
stupid yeah
that explains everything marxists are
allowed to have multiple properties one
that's 1.4 million dollars
they're allowed to that's normal for
marxists
landlords and property owners and you
know i
mean but it is in the kind of finest uh
soviet tradition right you have your
your dashes
and you have your dacas actually uh and
you have your kind of access to the
you know the super highway lane and
there's nothing new to i mean it's so
obvious for what it is um
what i think what is i mean there you
have right a great example of just
the the absurdity of the kind of work
thing that that that is white
supremacist that everything is white
supremacist
um and it does it is i mean
literally we are now living in a you
know kirby enthusiasm sketch
and and and you know i actually saw it
interview it was a few years ago
actually with larry david he was saying
oh you know we do have a lot of like
conservative viewers watch the show
and he's like it's kind of interesting
it's like yeah well because reality is
becoming that show
you know that it's that ridiculous i
mean it is interesting though that you
don't see
that many people on the kind of i guess
like bill maher does talk about this
a bit you know the absurdity of it but
it's kind of funny how
the crowd nervously laughs and the
guests
fee what's more interesting how these
high-profile guests
feel more of an impulse to be like well
bill you know
do you see that that lady who was that
lady she called gina carano a white
supremacist
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah former
senator yeah whoever she was she was
like wow you know she's a heidi heitkamp
right yeah yeah
and bill maher barely pushed back at all
right like
i you know if someone said that here i'd
be like that's not true you're lying
right like no not we're not playing that
game that's not true
and it's funny because i say this about
enrique tario the
the chairman of the proud boys literally
a black dude right and they're like he's
a white supremacist i'm like no he's not
no he's
he's literally black and proud boys have
multi-racial you can criticize the pride
boys for a lot of things yeah
just criticize them for the things that
are true right instead they lie and
i'll you're not i'm not going to play
that game bill maher should have come
out
and and and and been much more uh harsh
to this woman he's like she's not uh is
she really and then he goes well you
know
definitions change is that it i i also
think part of the interesting thing here
is you know it's like you know
this person's a nazi whatever and i find
you know my british
my american grandfather was pacific
marie still around 96 which is great
um and my british grandfather was a raf
bomber command pilot
and there's a lot of debate morally
right bombing german cities
but you know you study the nazis i
studied a lot of
about amateur albert but read a lot
about them
it it is kind of amusing with the
american like woke left talking nazi
white supremacy because they really
haven't
how many of them have read mine cap how
many of them have engaged seriously with
the literature to understand
because it is a profoundly unpleasant
ideology but but
simplifying it is not a good idea well
hold on i think many of them are in fact
familiar with it because
as we know james lindsay helen pluck
rose and peter pagosian
altered a portion of minecraft into
feminist ideology instead and it got
published in a scientific
journal so they've certainly read some
of the uh
i i think to be fair there's some heavy
criticism of that but the general idea
was
the intention and the targeting of
groups was what they ported over
and then someone accused them like all
they did was use the non-proper nouns
because the proper nouns were changed
and i'm like that's kind of the point
yeah
like when he's like this group is evil
and we're the best and here's our plan
and you just change the name of the
group that's kind of the point
yeah so these people that look they're
they're all about power
you know the the black lives matter
organization is basically saying we
don't pay her
she's not getting paid by us it's fake
news
um that's not the news the news is that
a prominent black lives matter activist
owns multiple homes and a very expensive
one
it's not i guess maybe some people infer
or assume
that she's making money from black lives
matter i didn't assume that i just
thought these people were hypocrites
claiming to fight for the common people
when actually they're just rich people
because i've seen it time and time again
al sharpton is the most ludicrous
personality
i mean it's quite astonishing actually
that you know you saw that
it was a few years ago that he needs his
first class you know
seat to go to speaking gigs and he
always turns up and then he disappears
uh i think michael brown's family were
talking about this how they felt they'd
been
and and it is just i mean the cost of it
is just
quite quite astonishing right that they
have uh we actually had an incident
where i live in washington and i don't
want to be too specific because it'll
seem like i'm using it
for my own but but a 19 year old black
guy was
shot and killed and no one
the reaction of people on the street who
were very much
you know defund the police signs yeah on
that night
uh was you know they weren't terribly
interested
uh as he was calling for help and and
there's more to it that but
but there is a lot of um again enter
profanity of choice that is really
not just pathetic but pretty outrageous
in the sense that these are people
you know people dying right we should
want solutions that
mitigate that you know you know what
i've been kind of pissed off about
i hear this a lot from a lot of
conservatives they'll say you know the
black lives matter people don't seem to
care about you know inner city youth or
what's going on in chicago and chiraq
right how come they don't protest and
demand justice for the black lives in
chicago
who are victims of this crime all the
time i hear that a lot
now i've met some people who do focus on
that and they're smaller community
community activists but definitely the
high profile grifters make their quick
buck
off pushing this institutional racism
narrative i got a similar complaint
though
where are the gun rights advocacy groups
and conservatives going into the same
neighborhoods and providing legal
defense
for the young black men whose only crime
was possession of a firearm right which
the second amendment says you're allowed
to do
it no it's a hugely good point you know
when when uh uh
well i'll just leave it at that without
you know getting into rehashing much of
all
i would say i don't know if he's been on
the show if not i mean obviously you
pick your own guess but show michael
singleton uh you know friend of mine
uh does a you know a black gun owner
does a tv show about it
uh engaged in you know some of this
stuff but um
you know so they're out you know there's
a actually though that's a very good
point
the judicial at the level of the big
well-funded conservative
legal defense things think representing
religious issues right
life that doesn't you know you're right
that there's there's that's a big gap
yeah there are a lot of uh particularly
young black men but even outside of that
there's a lot of people in this country
who get charged with a legal position of
a firearm and that's it
now if they're committing a crime with
the gun okay fine i get it
you commit a crime you commit a crime um
i mean like if they're robbing somebody
if they're carjacking or doing something
like that or using the gun in the price
of a crime
if someone literally is like i would
like to bear arms you know the
constitution says shall not be infringed
i would like to see you know the nra i'm
not a big fan of the nra but so i don't
think they would do anything but i'd
like to see more
gun rights groups actually be like we're
going to go to washington d.c we're
going to go to chicago we're going to go
to la we're going to go to compton we're
going to talk to these we're going to
find these young men
we're going to look at that that charge
sheet where it says illegal possession
of a firearm and we're going to be like
now we're going to give you the legal
defense
because this is not right second
amendment is clear right these guys
didn't do anything wrong
it's it's similar to how i think the
left overlooks
violent crime in this neighborhood as
well it's not going to play well i mean
we got a viral video that's been going
on for a while of a woman holding her
baby getting shot and killed and then
lying on top of her baby to protect her
from these drive-by shooters and a lot
of conservatives are like where is black
lives matter where's the left
complaining about this and i'm like
it's a good point you know they they
they scream
when there's a cop and an accidental uh
you know an accident occurs or a tragedy
or in this instance negligence
but they're not screaming when you know
things things go bad in chicago they're
not screaming about the gang violence
it's just the cops now i get it there's
a fair point too
cops aren't positions of authority right
so i understand that
and then there's an argument for the
conservatives it's like some of these
guys who have these guns are actually in
gangs
and they have guns for not good reasons
but at the same time i'm like
honestly man i think we need to have
some some principle in the matter
if we're if we're four black lives we're
for the gang members as well
and if we're for gun ownership we're
four gang members as well
one of the things that i i'm surprised
and
you know there may be well actually i
don't think there is a good reason for
it but why
uh we haven't seen more prosecutions um
the fbi atf
using ricoh statues so racketeering yeah
in the same way that they do against
russian organized crime eastern european
groups um
you know ms-13 whatever where
actually if you can build up your
evidentiary picture
you could have a pretty significant uh
judicial effect i think part of the
reason is that the
um you know the the some of the gangs
sometimes you know again you know that
young black men tend to be a part of
there's less um
you know the the economic impact on
society is lower
uh as a term in terms of criminal
finances and so
the incentive for the fbi is to go after
higher value things
right but at the moral level and the
life level you know you would think that
would be something perhaps everyone
could get behind
of course i'm sure i'm totally
delusional about that but
you know they're cr being creative here
right it is
um surely something we need to do more
of
um you know because it's it's
pretty you know again that those matches
yeah i think i got a good you know
overlapping nonprofit idea that i'm
gonna
see if i can you know get set up and i'm
you know so i've been talking to a few
people about this and it's quite
literally
to find young young men who are charged
with possession of a firearm and that's
it
and then so i think chicago is a good
target for this because
i think it'll be maybe this could be a
position where you know a lot of the
black lives matter people not who are
not to democratic establishment
where they're just anti-gun for no
reason but a lot of these actual leftist
personalities who believe in black lives
matter i'll be like how about we get
these guys out of jail and
help them get their lives fixed because
they didn't do anything wrong they're
abiding they're enjoying their second
amendment rights
and then i think a lot of the gun owners
libertarians and even some conservatives
might be like all right we agree with
that as well
so i'm like maybe that's a that's a good
thing where we can be like hey we're
going to do this thing don't
yell at us because we're trying to help
and you know make make lives better for
everybody
and and and i bet in a lot of those
cases right it's going to be
well we know it's it's that person
carrying that gun because they're in a
very high crime neighborhood and they
don't want to get robbed i mean it's
actually
it is basic level second amendment stuff
right just and
i mean yeah it's like very rudimentary
just self-defense right right i want to
prank myself and that's true for a lot
of these guys right
because i i'm from i'm from chicago i
see guys who are like i'll be damned if
i'm going to be a victim of these people
these gangs i don't have anything to do
with it but
right they want to defend themselves i
will say be really funny if we start
you know we find people with standing
you get it you get a young black man
he's got
you know a 1911 or something 45 and uh
he gets arrested and charged for that's
the only crime
the cops stop him you're under arrest
felony gun possession
we come in we say we're going to sue and
then it starts making its way up the
courts what are the democrats going to
do
what's their argument gonna be we're
actually defending the rights of
minorities
right and gunners at the same time are
they gonna come in and say that that
black man should be in jail
oh i'd love to see him do that no i
think that black men should not be in
jail i think he has a right to defend
himself the same as everybody else
i heard the black panthers were out in
minnesota on sunday morning and they
were armed to the teeth and i say good
yeah right they were allowed to do it
absolutely
nothing happened and nothing happened
well not from them right other people
went out later
and started trash and stuff it wasn't
the panthers right they have a
constitutional right to protect
themselves and to bear arms
and i think they're good american
citizens doing so right absolutely
totally agree
i'd like to see it happen we'll see
we'll see we'll see where we can go with
that yeah and again i i
i it's so instrumental right that that
is so
um talk about riots right in 2011 at
least in riots you know
as a gunner you can have a gun in your
home and you could at least have
relative confidence relative
um that you might be able to protect
your family uh
you know in 2011 in london there were
riots over three days and the cop
the police were totally overwhelmed
there was no
you know if you think about sort of
older people
uh people with health issues they it was
anarchy for them
people come into their homes you know
take stuff do whatever
and all that only recourse with the cops
and more than that the people doing it
knew that right
yeah here at least there is a moment of
pause you would hope
some people obviously there isn't but
but you know you're going to walk in and
you know good night i'll i'll tell you
this you know uh
out out in the middle of nowhere and uh
a little bit further west of where we
are
you see no trespassing sign yeah don't
come in yeah you definitely gonna obey
that trespassing sign
so like i've i've been out you know i
was thinking about this i was driving
through west virginia
and i look at all these houses and i'm
like you know
if you if you even thought of robbing
this house
you're gonna die right like don't commit
crimes and so i mean people are
reasonable they're not going to randomly
shoot a person they stay in the property
but they're going to warn you and
they're going to be armed with the teeth
most of the people who live out here
they're armed because cops are few and
far between right
so you know it's interesting to me like
i was mentioning earlier
the cost for the activist of getting
caught rioting is almost
nothing their life will not be harmed in
any way and it's really fascinating
because
destroying property burning things down
and literally causing harm to people
are very serious crimes yet going back
to this i hear these stories
of you know a you know 28 year old dad
in chicago
who's scared of gang violence so he gets
an illegal gun
it's not it's not literally illegal
according to the constitution but the
state says it is
and that's his crime he gets to go to
prison he gets locked up and have his
life ruined
because he wants to protect himself from
gang violence in a city the city
that the police can't control that to me
is insane
then you have these rioters who go out
destroy everything nothing happens to
him
it is interesting as well if we think
about the left's view on um voter id
laws right that is prohibitive in terms
of cost it
disproportionately affects minority
communities and yet the same principle
is not applied to well you to buy a
garden license to go through that room
well no that's okay that's something
could bring it's kind of interesting
yeah it's amazing voter id is racist
because it disenfranchises minorities
what about when menorahs want to go buy
a gun right is got gun ideas racist
right that's a funny thing too about
this voting stuff when i think it was
like david hogg who said
vote buying a gun shouldn't be easier
than voting and i was like
are you suggesting that guns should be
mailed to everyone's home when they
don't ask for it right
because mail and bailouts got mailed out
to everybody even if you ask for it or
not
could you imagine if you're like you
turn 18 and they mail you an ar-15
right i mean that'd be awesome
i'd be like great no that wouldn't be
awesome a lot of dumb people would have
i mean think about that a gun and just
line us to someone's mailbox
no that's not a good idea we don't want
to do that like i get it go to go to a
shop
you know have the weapon properly
transferred be responsible take it
seriously follow the rules
get you know safety training all stuff
be responsible but that's
that's just it's an amazing gap in uh
how they actually view the rights of
minorities it's politically useful to be
like voter id is wrong
okay well let's get them all guns i
think the black panther should have guns
absolutely
i think these people these people in
chicago minnesota wherever have a right
to have guns
where where yet democrats where's black
lives matter on this one yeah
we can all fight for this the black
panthers showed up in richmond virginia
i think it was
when the 2a people were all protesting
and it's funny how the media tries
framing the second amendment guys as
like white supremacists and i'm like
they're taking selfies the black
panthers smiling
right like these people are all very
much like libertarian like
hey man you get your gun i got mine and
well high five yeah yeah yeah
i was in texas years ago and i saw a
bunch of
you know guys look kind of like militia
guys standing around at a trump rally
with guns
and uh a guy showed up wearing a shirt i
think it was a black guns matter shirt
and it was a tall black dude with a
beard and a
some some you know probably a 556 air 15
of some sort and he walked right up to
these right-wing trumpsters and they
shook hands started talking laughing
with each other
and it's because they had common
interests they probably didn't agree
politically on certain things but they
were very much
pro-gun pro-liberty pro-each others
rights and both the white guy and the
black guy recognize each other as
respecting the rights
of the individual and that's what we
need more of thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show
come back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time